[Musique]
le chef du NPD lance cette semaine une
tournée nationale pour souligner les
pans du budget dont il est responsable
Jack meeting veut que les Canadiens
sachent que l'assurance dentaire dans le
budget libéral et d'abord et avant tout
une condition née au démocrate en
échange de son appui au gouvernement
minoritaire de Justin Trudeau comment
s'assurer que le message passe j'ai posé
la question au chef adjoint du NPD
Alexandre boules
Alexandre merci d'être avec nous ça fait
plaisir je voudrais
cette semaine
de l'Entente qu'on a négocié on a forcé
les libéraux à faire des choses que ils
ont jamais voulu faire auparavant le
gros morceau évidemment c'est
l'expansion des soins dentaires pour les
remboursements de facture cette année
pour les adolescents les personnes âgées
les personnes en situation d'handicap il
y a même pas deux ans les libéraux
avaient voté contre notre proposition de
soins dentaires là c'est dans le budget
et puis ça va aider des milliers de
personnes
la semaine dernière durant la conférence
de presse ou huis clos jamais prononcé
les lettres NPD et quand on lui parlait
de ce programme là non mais moi je suis
tellement fier de faire partie d'un
gouvernement qui a fait avancer ce
dossier là comment vous faites pour
apprendre le crédit mais l'entente qu'on
a négocié avec le gouvernement
minoritaire il y a 27 points c'est écrit
noir sur blanc c'est public on peut le
diffuser on peut le présenter aux gens
on peut présenter le vote de Madame
Freeland qui avait voté contre les soins
dentaires il y a même pas deux ans puis
de dire en sorte que vers le forcer les
libéraux à le faire ça va aider
concrètement des milliers de Québécois
puis des Québécoises dès cette année le
vieux que les enfants de 12 ans et demi
mais il faut que vous le dites oui faut
vous faire un temps puis le pays le
porte-voix gouvernemental est pas mal
plus fort que le vôtre c'est ça c'est
sûr que c'était un pari qui était un peu
risqué qu'on a pris quand on a décidé de
faire l'entente dans notre vie mais que
si ça aide concrètement la classe
moyenne les plus démunies tous les gens
qui ont pas d'assurance dentaire qui
couvrent les soins ça vaut la peine
après ça ben on fera des tourner on ira
en campagne électorale on fera du
porte-à-porte puis on dirait que c'est
grâce au NPD que ça a été fait mais ça
c'est le jeu politique et puis on verra
comment les électeurs vont réagir
l'autre élément l'autre élément que vous
avez aprement réclamé dont on parle
beaucoup c'est l'assurance médicament
votre chef tracé une ligne en disant moi
ça me prend quelque chose de concret
d'ici la fin de l'année il y a rien dans
le budget là-dessus ça c'était un peu
étonnant que je dois avouer il y avait
des choses importantes pour le mouvement
syndical qui était là la loi
anti-briseur de grève et mentionnée dans
le budget on aurait pu mentionner
l'assurance médicament c'était pas une
obligation mais le fait que ça soit
absent je vous que ça nous inquiète un
peu c'est une grosse demande de la FTQ
de la CSN de la CSQ au Québec ça va
faire une grosse différence dans le prix
des médicaments aussi pour monsieur
madame tout le monde tout le monde va
économiser pour nous c'est très
important au NPD donc là il y a un
échéancier il faut qu'il y a une loi
cadre sur l'assurance médicament avant
la fin de l'année
la portion ouvert
du budget qui mise beaucoup sur des
subventions investissements
développement technologies verte ça va
pas suffisamment loin au goût de votre
chef je vous ai entendu la semaine
dernière qu'est-ce qui manque vous avez
une inconfort c'est comme si les
libéraux fait la moitié du chemin puis
on comprend qu'il réagisse au plan Biden
parce que si on ne fait pas ce virage
vers les technologies vertes vers de
l'énergie propre mais on va être largué
on sera plus compétitif puis on va
perdre beaucoup d'emplois donc il
fallait agir là-dessus puis nous on a
poussé avec mon collègue Charlie Angus
sur la transition énergétique il y a des
éléments de ça mais tu as fait juste la
moitié du chemin si tu continues à
subventionner les compagnies pétrolières
s'il y a pas un cadre réglementaire qui
est fort pour forcer les gens parce que
si c'est juste des crédits d'impôts
remboursables tu as fait la moitié du
chemin parce que tu as pas d'obligation
réglementaire c'est ça qui manque en ce
moment c'est
tourne autour du réglementaire les
subventions pétrolières évidemment vous
en avez beaucoup parlé cette semaine
c'est ça l'élément le plus important le
plus ce qui manque c'est ce qui manque
parce que c'est la partie obligation
c'est la partie plus contraignante le
crédit d'impôt si tu fais pas
l'investissement si tu fais pas la
dépense si la compagnie c'est le temps
pas de le faire mais le gouvernement a
pas de contrôle là-dessus c'est le privé
qui décide donc c'est un peu croiser les
droits puis espérer qu'ils vont le faire
comment ça se passe en négociation avec
les libéraux
ça se passe de manière hebdomadaire et
un comité de suivi du respect de
l'Entente trois députés libéraux 3
députés néo-démocrates donc on a des
rencontres régulières des fois on avance
des fois on avance pas assez vite des
fois on aura pas mais la relation est
comment c'est il y a une ouverture il y
a une réelle ouverture il y a une écoute
puis on est capable de jouer notre rôle
parce qu'on a un rapport de force on a
une influence on a la base du pouvoir
puis on l'utilise donc c'est
complètement une autre partie c'est
complètement un autre jeu politique par
rapport au gouvernement majoritaire que
moi par exemple j'ai connu dans le passé
donc
on en profite on a le pied en porte puis
on est capable de faire avancer des
dossiers est-ce que c'est merveilleux
est-ce qu'on obtient tout ce qu'on veut
non mais on a une grosse influence pour
un caucus de 25 député comment c'est
d'être assis du côté de l'opposition
d'essuyer les critiques des voisins d'à
côté les conservateurs qui à chaque
période des questions finissent par vous
ramasser sur quelque chose c'est
invariable écoutez êtes-vous et moi là
que les conservateurs critiquent le NPD
puis que il trouve qu'on fait pas un bon
travail moi ça me rassure à quelque part
et puis si il nous critique puis
vraiment ils prennent du temps pour
parler du NPD mais ça veut dire que dans
certaines parties du pays on est une
menace et puis il faut qu'ils nous
prenne en compte sur le budget
j'aimerais revenir là-dessus le déficit
le déficit qui a été qui était annoncé
par Madame Freeland et la situation
financière du gouvernement canadien
est-ce que le gouvernement peut tenir ça
encore longtemps parce que c'est c'est
s'exposer aux critiques de façon
importante ça peut devenir un élément un
élément problématique revien Dra le
temps de retourner en campagne
électorale et pour eux et pour vous je
pense qu'il faut être responsable avec
l'argent de l'argent public mais il faut
en même temps que les gens en aient pour
leur argent donc améliorons la situation
réelle la crise du logement est pour
régler encore des investissements à
faire pour nous les noms démocrates ce
qui est important c'est d'améliorer la
vie des gens d'abord et avant tout puis
faire payer les Ultra riches puis on
aura à terme un équilibre budgétaire
alexandredi merci beaucoup ça fait
plaisir